willing to go to break but shaquille
o'neal your name up came up about two
dozen times
a lot of roses coming your way shaq uh
first of all you have to be thrilled
about all those compliments but i'm just
curious is it okay that
they're already putting lebron and a.d
on the list of
laker great duos and this is their first
finals
well one that's that's not about me i
haven't played in 10 years i'd rather be
mentioned with kenny
yourself granting that uh you know it's
a honor to to be mentioned
you know i when i went there i wanted to
also make a name for myself and those
two guys are definitely making
a name for themselves you know they're
dominant you know they're doing what
everyone in la la land expects them to
do
and they're playing great but again this
is not about me this is about the l.a
lakers versus the miami heat
and look they just went out and play you
know again
uh going to the finals in 94 95 getting
embarrassed
by kenny i always said to myself if i
make it back to the finals again i have
to dominate dominate dominate don't be
nice
bully ball elbow people throw them out
the way and of course i had the best
player in the world on my team but
listen we had big shoes to follow you
see magic and kareem
they really started the whole you know
showtime thing they paved the way
so when i first got there jerry west sat
me down kitty and he said look i know
you want to do albums
i know you want to do movies and he
pointed up to the raptors he said but if
you want to be a laker great
i need you and kobe to step up and start
winning championships so
lebron thank you for mentioning my name
but it's not about me i haven't played
10 years
i got my stuff right here i'm happy with
this even though i should have had six
because we should have beat them rockets
but i told nick anderson don't jump on
the pump fake and he jumped on the pump
fake and my main man kenny hit the three
everybody always forgets jerry west and
will chamberlain like
those two dodge duo is just as good as
anybody that would have played in
in this era for sure um or any other so
there's a legacy of lakers you know you
can make all-time great teams just by
taking lakers and celtics you know those
two franchises have
produced the greatest players that's
ever played the game so uh
i will say that anthony and and and
and uh lebron they have an opportunity
to do something that
that kobe and shy because they're in
them
like anthony's in his prime and
and and lebron not fading
so what happens is now you know you have
a guy who's in his prime and then it
lasts longer
like kobe was coming into it shaq was
not fading at that time at all
so he was still in his you know his
momentum
even though this is lebron's 17th year
he's in his momentum
so this is something that could be
special for the next three or four years
you know obviously the west is tough
with the clippers that are in the same
arena right now
and you talk about the uh golden state
warriors possibly coming back and
portland all those things but i don't
think that lebron and a.d are worried
uh about any of that they're saying
we're here
we we we we have now they have the
experience grant
of being there together i would like to
see them
i would have liked to see them with the
fans in the building i would like to see
the capuso and danny greens on the road
in miami you know south beach going
crazy i would have loved to see
that environment to get game three and
then i i like that would be something
different
i i agree with i agree with you kenny i
mean i think first of all
both of you guys have won and and and
winning a championship
and bringing that core back the
confidence you have the know-how
and if they they're able to pull this
out uh and win this series
and win and be champions that confidence
and and the way lebron has taken care of
his body
there's some runway that these guys have
and they have an opportunity
to to win some games here so i just got
to say
you know 83 points shack
and games one and two like that's
like for all them young kids out there
that are staying up late
that was a bad man right there i didn't
like that 41 and a half
you know that was grant you know that
grandma that was barbecue
chicken alert barbecue chicken alert
rick smith
rick smith the davis boys that's
barbecue chicken alert down there
there's the shack we all know and love i
was wondering where you went all that
humble talk earlier i couldn't believe
it i thought somebody came in with the
invasion of the body snatchers earlier
that's the shack i know exactly i